دفع تعدد استخدامات الذكاء الاصطناعي نحو
صعودي نهج جديدا للحرب يعرف باسم الحرب
الذكيه او الحرب القائمه على الذكاء
الاصطناعي شيئا فشيئا تقلل اسلحه الذكاء
الاصطناعي اعتمادها على العنصر البشري ومع
تفوق التقنيه وسرعتها مقارنه بالانسان قد
يغيب العنصر البشري تماما الخطر هنا هو ان
الذكاء الاصطناعي يخطئ احيانا الرادارات
في بعض الاوقات ترى الطائره صديقه كطائره
عدو مثلا فماذا ان كان قرار الضربه الاولى
عائد له ماذا لو قصفت مسيره امريكيه هدفا
صينيا كان المقصود مراقبته فقط كيف ستطمئن
واشنطن الطرف الاخر بان الحادث كان غير
مقصود ولم يتكرر
اجابت بنفسها على السؤال في هذا الاعلان
[موسيقى]
حتى الاسلحه التي لا تعمل بالكامل بالذكاء
الاصطناعي خطره مثلا في عام 2003 اسقطت
18 اسقطت عفوا
ثمانيه عشر هورنت بواسطه الصاروقي باتري
السلاحان الامريكيه بالطبع النظام الاليمي
للباتريت اخطا وعرف الهرنيت كطائره معاديه
تستهدفها المشغلون البشريون حروب الذكاء
الاصطناعي ليست خيالا علميا الامر واقع
حتى وان كانت الانظمه غير كامله كما ذكرنا
وهناك للعلم واحده دائره ولو جزئيا حاليا
حرب اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات